secrétaire national du secours populaire
sébastien tholot bonjour sébastien tobo
merci de répondre à nos questions le
confinement a engendré plus de provo de
pauvreté pourtant les français ont
beaucoup épargné pendant la mise sous
cloche 37 milliards d'euros placés sur
des comptes de type livret a entre le 31
décembre et 30 août sur dans le figaro
alors effectivement une partie de la
population a pu épargner mais on peut
aussi rappeler que avant le début de
l'épidémie il y avait les yeux à 9
millions de personnes sous le seuil de
pauvreté donc des personnes qui
n'étaient pas concernés par ces mesures
d' épargne et qui ont subi de plein
fouet
l'épidémie et a notamment toutes les
conséquences qu'il ya pu avoir notamment
pour des femmes seules avec des enfants
qui devaient d'un seul coup les nourrir
puisque les comptines été fermées donc
un tas de conséquences qui ont été
dramatiques pour une bonne partie de la
population et l'arrêt économique et de
beaucoup d'activités ont aussi été
ressenti par beaucoup de travailleurs
précaires ou une public où les deux
personnes qui avaient des bouleaux et
qui s'en sortait juste et qui sont
tombés dans la précarité
près de 23 millions de personnes ont
sollicité l'aide du secours populaire
pendant le confinement dans 45 %
jusque-là inconnu de
votre association quels sont les profils
de ces personnes de ces nouveaux venus
1 c'est vrai que nous avons vues sur
l'ensemble du territoire que ce soit
dans les grandes villes les banlieues
les territoires périurbains ou le milieu
rural une arrivée de nouvelles personnes
de nouveaux publics
comme je les dis il y avait déjà les
femmes seules avec enfants qui se sont
retrouvés à devoir gérer une un budget
déjà contraint il y avait aussi des auto
entrepreneurs des gens qui avaient des
contrats précaires des cdd qui se sont
retrouvés
arrêté il ya eu également des petits
commerçants des petits artisans qui ont
vu leurs commandes s'arrêter également
ou baisser fortement
et puis une hausse aussi sans précédent
d'étudiants qui sont venus franchir la
porte de notre association dans tous les
lieux d'études
donc ça veut dire des inégalités
scolaires se sont des inégalités
scolaires alors qu'ils se sont retrouvés
bien sûr parra pour les étudiants alors
les étudiants c'était une égalité
d'abord deux pour beaucoup d'étudiants
qui arrive à sentir s'en sortir juste en
travaillant notamment en temps des
extras dans la restauration dont ils
n'ont plus aucune ressource
ils n'ont pas ou très peu pu bénéficier
de jobs d'été pour pour beaucoup et les
inégalités sur le coup scolaires aussi
se sont accrues puisque dans le cadre du
baromètre l'ipsos secours populaire 44%
des parents qui ont été sondés estiment
que leurs enfants ont lu un retard un
retard scolaire et notamment pour les
familles que nous accueillons d'une aux
problématiques d'accès à internet ou de
nos matériels informatiques pour
permettre aux enfants de suivre leur
scolarité dans ce durant ces quatre à
cinq mois qu'il y a eu pendant avant là
avant l'été qu'est ce que vous demandez
pas ce que l'on vient de
d'établir un constat on a parlé de 1,3
million de personnes qui sont venus vous
voir pendant le confinement mais mais
mais qu'est ce que vous demandez
justement
selon vous la solution c'est quoi s'il
en a il ya vous touchez le secours
populaire n'a pas de solution a comme
ceux ci nous nous sommes d'abord dont
deux dans des conséquences et prendre
notre part dans les conséquences de
cette crise de pouvoir améliorer et
renforcer certaines pratiques de
solidarité
je pense notamment à la question de
l'accès au numérique
ça va être notre association un vrai
défi une fois que l'on a fait le constat
de cette non de son nom accès au
numérique et au droit qui sont attachées
par rapport au gouvernement qu est ce
que vous demandez à l'exécutif
aujourd'hui de ce que nous avons
constaté c'est que des moyens sont mis
sur différents différents champs et nous
nous souhaitons que le champ social soit
aussi reconnu avec des moyens
nécessaires pour éviter que les
personnes tombent dans une précarité ou
de pauvreté plus important donc les
moyens financiers tels qu'ils ont été
mis sur 20 notamment la question de
l'aide alimentaire doivent perdurer et
doivent aussi avoir une visibilité
la première chose c'est bien sûr de
garder de personnes de pouvoir retrouver
un emploi donc la question économique
mais tous ceux qui en sont exclus
aujourd'hui il doit y avoir des mesures
fortes qui doivent être prises pour
garantir à la fois des minima sociaux et
éviter de tomber dans une précarité
encore plus importante
et quand la mise du travail elisabeth
bornes dit aujourd'hui que le chômage
partiel à 100% pour tous les secteurs
protégés va perdurer et c'est une bonne
nouvelle cela envoie ça va dans le bon
sens un belle mine toute mesure de ce
type va dans le bon sens
il ya aussi toutes les personnes qui
sont aux joueurs qu'ils étaient avant
l'épidémie en situation de chômage donc
la question du chômage partiel de
l'entreprise dans laquelle ils n'étaient
pas ne les concernait pas il ya aussi
les personnes qui se retrouvent avec des
minima sociaux il ya des personnes
notamment les personnes
adultes handicapés qui ne se retrouvent
pas dans ces dispositifs la donc la
question est celle d'un côté des
personnes qui sont encore un emploi et
dans leurs entreprises de mettre en
chômage partiel et avec une mesure à
100% il ya déjà tous ceux qui ne
pouvaient pas en bénéficier avant et sur
lequel il faut aussi se pencher
sérieusement merci
sébastien tholot d'avoir répondu à la
question je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire national du secours populaire